okay thank you um something to talk
about becoming Gotham Oh morphisms as
you can see it's a drag work with Andres
Galan is mark jerem who are around here
somewhere
and Andres gets extra credit for drawing
the pictures which could you'll see it
would be impossible to explain without
so so slides um and some of the things
that I'll mention have been in the
bootcamp and if you weren't at the boot
camp or even if you were please stop me
and if anything is unclear I'd rather
explain it so so feel free to interrupt
anytime
okay so graph lemma morphisms so I'm
gonna call them each colorings as
they're sometimes called um so let me
start by just telling you what one is
who are reminding you of an H color a
Laura graph on the morphism is a map
from a graph G to another graph H which
I'm going to call the template just to
avoid confusion and all it is is it's a
map from the vertices of G to the
vertices of H and it has to have one
property which is that edges have to map
to edges okay so I've drawn the picture
here here's our about G and I I've
thrown the map from the vertices of G to
the vertices of H so that guy's got red
back I've got blue green etc on this map
that I drew is a homomorphism because
red is allowed to be adjacent to blue
and blue to itself and blue
there's no red next to red in this
picture otherwise it wouldn't be a
humble morphism okay so the rest of the
talk is about that so I would pause is
that clear okay so that's what a graph
of a morphism or H coloring is sometimes
we refer to the nodes of H as colors
all right so what's in the common truck
problems can be represented as drive
homomorphisms or H colorings so for
example if I check H to be this little
graph here with two vertices at one self
loop then homomorphisms to this H are
independent sets because I could think
of red as being in the independence at
it blue it's beating out that takes a
map from the vertices of G to red and
blue but I don't have in next in it's an
independent set okay I guess the other
classic example if I take a clique for
example a clique of size three but
homomorphisms from a graph G to a clique
our proper three colorings because this
H has all edges except for self loops so
I can color red green blue hobro like
provided I don't put a color next to
itself okay so by varying the template
age we varied the problem that I was
independent sets that guy was colorings
and of course we could take any H we
like okay so that's wouldn't H coloring
it now I'm going to talk about so this
workshop should be about the
classification program and complexity so
I'm going to start by giving you a
little survey about algorithmic problems
to do with H colorings
so I'm gonna start with the edge
coloring decision problem and Helen s
eternal both here this route this work
really could have initiated this area
and the question they studied was
supposed to fix a template egg okay so
just just fix that and now what if I
have an input graph G that's the input
so the question is does G have an H
covering okay
so what they showed
is that this problem is in P if H has a
loop or if it's bipartite but for every
other single fixed H they consider the
problem sin be complete okay so let's
think through this on the NP is the easy
direction so let's do that that's easy
okay so let's look at an H with a loop
suppose I take an input G and I want to
say does G have a homomorphism to this H
the answer is yes right because you
could just map everything to put it's
got the loop so all edges are mapped to
edges is that obvious
and so that's easy the other thing
that's easy is that
it's in P if H is bipartite so let me
talk you through that suppose I have a
biker my graph H and I want to check
with others of them a morphism from some
input G to H well first if G has an odd
cycle then the answer is no because how
could you put an odd cycle into a
bipartite graph there's nowhere for it
to go okay so now let's suppose I have a
graph G that's my markup let's assume
for a minute that it's connected how
many homomorphisms are there two H well
one side of G could go to this side of H
the other side could go to the other
side and then you're home free
yep so I'm sorry I'm nothing counting
we're trying to the decision Samantha to
an inch okay if it's bipartite Memphis
to an edge and you're good okay so those
are the easy and what was really great
about their work was not that but the
fact that they managed to show that for
every single other H it's np-complete so
it's just comprehensive every other H
that's it so we completely understand
all H these are easy everything else
hard and so that was a substantial
effort and they're not going to tell you
how to do the hard thing okay now this
is what I started jumping into it so
badly but if we're interested in not
decision but counting out again this is
something thoroughly study by Dyer in
Greenville and here's the theorem that I
gave the question is in McGruff G how
many H colorings are there so again we
want to know if you're given an input
graph G how many home one more visits
from G to H okay
so what did they show first of all let's
suppose that G the H is a click with all
loops so every edge that could be there
is it there okay now let's go for a
minute I want to consider counting
homomorphisms from a connected graph G
to this what's the answer
well if G has n vertices then it's 3 to
the N right you can just do anything cuz
all the edges with them okay oh yeah um
look another easy bit what if H is a
complete bipartite graph what if G is
connected and I'm gonna get back to the
connectivity thing in a minute Holly
homomorphism very MGH well if G has an
odd cycle 0 anywhere what if it doesn't
have an odd cycle this is the bed I was
jumping to before well what can you do
it's bipartite put one side of G to one
side the other to the other and now
can do everything okay just so multiply
out okay know what they show those are
the two easy cases now let's stop for a
minute
what if G is not connected okay well if
you wanted to come home the morphisms
from G to H what would you do you take
each connected component of G count
homomorphism stage and then multiply
yeah so that's what you do if G is re H
is connected
what if H is not connected you would add
right if I wanted to do homomorphisms
from G to a graph that has this
component and that one G's connected
send it here send it there
okay so connectivity is no issue for in
this easy direction and so the easy part
of the theorem is that every connected
component if it's a clique with all
loops or a complete bipartite graph then
this is easy and again the deep part of
their theorem is that if H even has the
component that doesn't look like this
then it's actually number patiently okay
so what pause because I think I are
there any just means what you can
compute in polynomial time so f is
whatever you can do in polynomial time
but it's not a decision probably outputs
a number so that's what it's called I
think anymore things I forgot to explain
okay many people here or fun actually
approximately the single thing was there
because this is a complete bipartite
graph of any loops and I just wanted to
make the point that this is this should
be counted in this but
are you gonna give us an idea of
hardness results I'm going to give you
an idea about approximate hardness and
if you that'll give you some idea and
then if you want to talk about exact we
should probably do it after yeah but
you're right so far I'm telling you the
stuff that you could figure out in five
minutes and not the deep stuff it's hard
okay so little but approximate counting
so as people who've been here a while
and people who haven't probably know
that one of the kind of standards for
success and approximate counting is the
F Prize so that's the notion that we've
been used so beginner the question that
is going to be fixed H the template in
photograph G and now also and put in
accuracy we've got your wrist and
parameter if I can say it and what you
want to do is you want that output a
number which is with high probability
quite close to the number of H colorings
how close well it should be you know
which is the parameter epsilon controls
how close and is epsilon being smaller
and closer the running time surrounded
by a polynomial and VM whatever I want
okay so that's what we're gonna use I
think we're [ __ ] introduced this here
1 plus or minus sub soiler that's the
same thing so I just rub it this way so
ii yeah okay all right so so that's the
question we're going to talk about next
how hard is it to approximately count it
oh thanks and as a warm-up I put up
three vertex itches and like Dominic
Welsh always used to do a color coded
them and I'm gonna use this slide as a
way to introduce some ideas that I think
a lot of people know and then we'll move
on so these are three vertex connected
graphs H I've drawn on the isomorphic
ones and the question is how hard is it
to approximately count H colors okay so
the first thing I'll draw your attention
to
the green ones okay you can see this is
easy but this is easy to count exactly
right we just saw that same thing this
is a complete bipartite graph so we know
it's easy to count the morphisms to that
so those guys are easy alright and the
next thing I want to do is I want to
glance at all the red ones and the red
ones have the property that it's np-hard
to approximately count graph
homomorphisms and we're not gonna define
formally in this talk because it's not
very important but I'm not going to
define the notion of approximate
approximation preserving reductions but
basically an approximation preserving
reduction between two counting problems
house exactly the property you expect
that there if you can F Prize one you
can have press the other okay so that
means they're sort of equivalent and
these red guys are equivalent to
counting satisfying assignments and
what's known is that actually is hard to
approximately count as anything in
number P so some of this we've done
before in the bootcamp and that means
that if you could approximately count
you would know that NP is equal to RP so
those guys are really as hard as can be
within the class and over P and I'm
going to take questions on this because
I think this this is kind of a
background slide without saving stuff so
but let me draw your attention to this
blue guy so there's one odd one out
there in this picture and this blue guy
is exactly is difficult to approximately
count as counting independent sets in
bipartite graphs so if you hear you
probably think yeah you've heard a
million talks about that otherwise it
might seem a little strange but the
point about counting independent sets in
bipartite graphs is that it's equivalent
in difficulty of approximation as loads
of other problems and it's completing
this are logically defined
class which I would define our H by one
and it's tend to believe to be of
intermediate difficulty so we don't
really believe there's an X press for
that but neither do we really believe
it's as hard as the red guys but this is
a classification program and what's
going on with these three vertex graphs
is that we understand all of them these
guys are easy this one is complete for
this intermediate class it's exactly in
difficulties coming independent sets in
a bipartite graph which is the canonical
for that class these guys are all
equivalent accounting satisfying
assignments which is a quick the hardest
you can be in number P okay but not
everybody was here for the bootcamp so
our learning is any queries about that
that's the kind of basic framework that
we're gonna work in and I haven't told
me anything about HS that have more than
three vertices yeah okay okay so that's
three vertex H long time ago and the
truth is despite that we still don't
know everything there is to know about
all age so as the talk goes on you'll
see that there are going to be some
things we know but we we don't have a
beautiful classification for all age
such as the ones that I showed you for
decision and for the exact count so I'll
show you what we do know but it's less
than everything okay okay so here we go
we don't have a truck outta me for all
connected H and I thought before I go on
to what we know it gives you an example
of what we don't know because it's so
simple
there are even for vertex graphs whose
consent city we don't understand
so three we knew everything but if you
just go up to four open problems believe
it or not and here's an example of a
graph that we don't know its complexity
so we we do know that this isn't harness
this
independence a bipartite graphs but we
don't know whether it's as hard as that
so um it may live in between four oh no
and there are other such problems and
Stephen Phelps States this has the of a
whole bunch of them this particular
problem is interesting because it's
equivalent to counting four colorings
and my part on graphs if your input is
bipartite and so counting colorings of
bipartisan some class of problems that
may live between bits and sat we'd we
don't really know so that's quite
interesting so I just want to draw your
attention to that is something that's
not understood what's the evidence that
this starship yeah so much in case we do
the questions what's the evidence of the
vistas intermediate and I wouldn't say
that there is very strong evidence so
one thing that happens with this news
the problems have a feeling about them
this is getting really weird anyway it's
kind of a parody like feeling maybe they
have it they have a feel but you can
spot and quite a lot of problems that
are really apparently different turn out
to be equipment like so one I think is
the most strange is coming stable
matchings for example so the evidence is
that there are a lot of problems that
turn out to the equivalent and they feel
a little bit different but we don't have
good and I mean they could all be hard
and we're just too stupid yeah but I can
all be expressible get anything but so
what I'm gonna tell you about it in this
talk is um something mark likes to call
them no life
anyway um it's about whether there can
be things that are easier than this but
for which we don't know if prices is
gonna get gold and so what the punchline
by telling you that what we what we've
rigged in this work is that there are no
ages apart from the trivial ones that
are easier than this everything's at
least this hard so I'm gonna get there
um but before I get there I'm gonna take
a detour into the complexity of sampling
and the reason for that is that um it's
easier and I'm gonna tell you about so
much all the work that we did on
sampling and then I'm gonna talk about
the problems of moving that to counting
them and how how have some has some work
of lavishes which was always there we
just didn't know about it is the missing
ingredient that helps um fill in the
picture for counting okay so let me talk
briefly about sampling and you'll see
why I don't want to do it very formally
but um a polynomial approximate sample
or would you need to know roughly what
that is for sampling each colourings so
the inputs to the meograph and an
accuracy parameter akin epsilon epsilon
and the output is now going to be a
random edge coloring drawn from some
distribution and the point should just
be oh it doesn't really matter exactly
what distribution the outputs are from
but the total variation distance between
the Aqua distribution and the uniform
distribution on H coloring should be
small so you can output from any
distribution as long as it's close in to
other variation to uniform and the
runtime can depend on the number of
vertices in the pile on and we could
make this a fully polynomial
approximation scheme by demanding that
you spend a little less time with that
parameter I don't want to spend very
long on it cuz that's not very important
the important thing is the idea you're
just sampling H colorings from a
distribution close to uniform okay so we
have an old theorem which I want to talk
about a little bit which says if you
take any
eh which is fixed as usual and doesn't
have any trivial components okay then if
you could sample from close to the
uniform distribution so I think I make
an H colouring nearly uniformly random
then you could F prize this okay so
that's kind of abyss hardness but no oh
sorry that's so you can't run base so
obviously you could have price
everything in that class already 2 pi at
one but the thing I expect knows what I
wanted to say about this is it doesn't
tell you about approximate counting so
normally with self reducibility brought
for self reducible problems we think of
approximate counting we know that
approximate comes in at sampling or
basically of the same difficulty and
then that's truth my goes back to the
jerem Valiant another on e but here we
have a result that says if you could
sample h colorings then you could sample
independent sets in the bipartite graph
that's self reducible so you could
approximately count independent sets in
a bipartite graph hence you could do
everything about this class so the
weaker result it just shows hardness for
sampling doesn't tell you anything about
approximate counting and i'm gonna talk
a little bit more about why this is
easier to prove and then a little bit
we'll come back to 'county understand
assembly
sure and let me so the intuition is
probably more important than the details
so the intuition should be the end of
what is G the output is a an H coloring
of G and the distribution from what your
algorithm chooses the output should be
close to uniform but it doesn't have to
be perfect that's there's some accuracy
and yeah so you're trying to measure how
difficult it is to do this yes exactly
so this is a computational problem
because the Buffington treaty on the
accuracy parameter my mind is wandering
out of it is there a polynomial time
algorithm obviously I got to be around a
Mize polynomial time perfect thanks and
then thank you and please that feel
pretty good okay
okay so I wanna make one remark before
going on is that when we get to
approximate counting actually whether
the thing is connected or not make some
difference so I told you for dire
Greenhills result that of they had the
very strong result that if you have any
hard component then the whole problem
becomes hard well that's not truth for
sampling and maybe just ignore the words
but look at this picture and all I
wanted to draw your attention to is that
the graph H that consists of both of
these components is one for which it's
actually easy to approximate they count
H colorings and here's and I don't want
you to compute the technical difficulty
tails because they don't matter but it
just here's the point
suppose I was faced with this H and I
wanted to UM I wanted to pick around Oh
more or approximately count H colorings
here's what I do
I'd say what is my give an accuracy
parameter is it really really small if
it's really really small I have a lot of
time and I have so much time that I just
count the independent sets of the graph
so I know how many and that I know what
three
and is and I pick one randomly okay what
if epsilon is not so small so I don't
have much time then I just ignored this
component and I just pick around a
problem or ISM from my gravity here and
the Dinos only book but it's very turn
it's good enough it works okay so you
gather approximately camera out of that
so unlike the case for exact counting we
do have to worry about components and
what I'm gonna tell you for the rest of
this talk is gonna be about commit
alright so I said that okay oh yeah okay
so do you want to make one more point
here so I've talked about the fact that
for self reducible problems approximate
sampling and approximate how to make the
same um we do know from the paper from a
long time ago that that there are
technical problems where they aren't the
same so we have a paper from a long time
ago that showed that if you could
approximately count that sorry if you
could approx sample these colorings then
you could approximately count them so we
know one direction the other direction
we don't know but this paper to give a
little artificial example including
discrete Margit is everything that it
was to show that you always go the other
way so there was a little problem in
number P which subject to some
complexity theory assumptions you can
approximately count but not sample so
but we have to consider the possibility
that they're not always at the same
complexity okay you know you keep saying
a long time ago 4:20 on the floor
all right so yeah I mean so the
questions that motivated the current
work which is my Tristan yeah we wanted
to know is there a graph for which
approximately counting is actually
easier that are approximately sampling
and also within those a graph that lies
between pmbus and it turns out in this
case we found there's not so I'll tell
you a bit about that in this case you
know there still could be a fits inside
there different one up there we don't
know so finally young the theorem that I
was going to tell you about now which um
which is Mark um okay so that's what it
is so what if the talking about so let H
be a graph we always have self loops
possibly parallel edges is not very
interesting them you don't have them
connected components need to be
non-trivial otherwise we don't know
so there's another project and what we
show is that the approximately Counting
edge colorings is always at least as
hard as this so we're not gonna formally
defined the reduced ability but what
we're going to show is that if you could
approximately count each color into
account indeed okay so and the key
technique is going to be that's enabled
us to do it in the counting world is to
show that gadgets exist using kinda
non-constructive tools on through the
lotsa globish so we're not always going
to have the gadgets that we need to hand
but rather we're going to sort of show
there they exist so that's so okay so
let me start with a very high-level
proof overview and then i'm gonna kind
of veer into feeling showing how to do
some of it in sampling which is a little
bit easier and then come back and show
how the stuff Lots who really is very
very useful okay so what if we wanted to
show that for every non-trivial
age that counting approximately H
colorings is this huh so obviously you
gotta handle all ages somehow are there
so a natural way to do is by induction
so we know how to handle two types HS so
that's nice so faceplates of three or
whatever base cases are pretty good so
for the inductive step what we'd love to
do what anybody might try is we might
like to find given a graph H some
smaller graph H prime which itself has
no trivial components so that we can
inductively handle it
and then we just want to prove that H
prime colorings
reduces to H coloring right if we can so
we could carry out this scheme we would
we would that would be a good scheme
right so we know for all two different
graphs that all non-trivial ones are bit
hard because indeed if there's a system
different Express and the only
non-trivial one is independence that
andum
so the idea is just given any H we want
to identify a smaller H which doesn't
have any trivial components so that we
can deal with it and reduces stage okay
like a good plan and so of course the
main task is figuring out given a graph
H how to find such an H prime so that's
what I'm gonna talk to you about okay so
by many of the slides I think there was
a talk the other day that had a first
attempt on caramel visible and where
here's a first attempt I said let me
show you how you might find such a such
an H and this will give a hint on how
it's done and how it's not done in all
sorts of things so let's say that we
want to find such
well I'm gonna just work by example so
here's H might look a little exotic but
it would interpret illustrate a few
things um
this H is rather easy for me they're not
easy enough because it has a unique
we're types of maximum degree so I'm
gonna illustrate some things using this
age what if I wanted to show that this H
was hard by just doing the inductive
step
okay well this vertex here has a unique
vertex of maxillary degree and so I want
to think about how I can use that okay
and then what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to identify say I'm gonna let these star
be this unique guy a little an H star B
the graph induced by its neighborhood
so I hope you can see the colors it's in
red here so there's this path length I
am then there's this thing here that's
induced by the neighborhood of my guy
and well okay that's smaller and it has
no trivial components and what I'm going
to try and show you is that indeed a
Starkel reduces to H so we're working
towards this very elementary in W scheme
okay and here's how you would do it okay
so this is a quite nice one so here's
how you might do it suppose I wanted to
show that H start coloring is produced H
of colorings well all I would do is I
would take some input - H star colorings
will take a huge independent set and I
would construct a graph like this okay
so I think this is hopefully cut easy to
see now what would happen if I
approximately counted edge colorings of
this graph
well this independent set is huge so in
a typical H coloring this vertex W would
have to get color to be stopped right
because it's the unique vertex of Maps
degree and that gives you the
here okay is that okay so I thought when
I do them because I'm gonna move I'm
lettin let me just like that I decided a
few sprigs that maybe looks like matter
well okay so I've got breath age and
what we're trying to do is this
inductive scheme
okay so Lauren trying to do is pick out
a graph H prime which made me sub graph
and it should have no trivial components
and it should be smaller okay and that's
because by induction we've showed that
counting H prime colorings is this hard
and so you've only been I want to do is
show that reducing 8h front fillings
reduces to H colors did that work
everyone yeah okay then for this graph
here which is just one example I wanted
to show you it's quite easy so what I
want to show you that it's easy for this
graph and I one of pods enough to make
that clear because otherwise the next
video will just be too confusing so for
this graph H prime is that red thing
okay right I lost everybody and I I
don't release it no except for Marco
yes and I'm sorry for that that's them
that's suggest about family cuts the
confusion in the general induction
scheme okay we've got a graphic age we
want to find a sub graph H find that is
smaller has non-trivial components and
reduces to H now I'm giving you a
particular example and in the particular
example it's annoying that this is cause
this is a cold h star it's for reasons
that are not very interesting
actually maybe so unfortunately just H
start is it is H Prime and that is
probably because the confusion obviously
sorry okay oh yeah Martin here one step
ahead of me that is the next slide but
in looking for that correct so I'm
showing you an easy case and then I'm
gonna get to a hard case and other cases
okay sorry
so this particular day just is gonna be
the easiest one and how easy it is let's
look at it I want everybody to
understand what this look is so I have
this unique vertex of e star maximum
degree I will don't always have that but
here I do okay so what I do is when I
let take an input of H star coloring
okay I know by induction that's hard
okay now what I do is I construct this
graph and I put a vertex here and
connect it to all of those guys and
connected to everything in some huge
independent set now let's see what would
happen if we took an H coloring of this
thing in an H color of this thing this
vertex has enormous degree enormous so
it will be colored V stock because if
it's not colored V star there's not much
you can do right here this degree one
two three four five six seven there are
said
way as i compeller all of this so if
this has n vertices I get a factor of
seven to M that's just watching
everything so in the ones that are
really going to count this is going to
become a TV star if it is colored blue
star what do we have here oh good we
have an H star color okay all right now
for Martin's ahead of me good but there
are lots of reasons this scheme may not
work in general for example um H star
might have trivial components so the
induction will go through right that's
that's certainly possible and or else
the star of H star might be H so then
I'm I'm doing induction from the same
problem that's not induction or there
might even be multiple vertices of
maximum in degrees so there might not
even be such a nice thing and all those
are problems and I just thought I'd give
you some examples that Martin already
hooked you that one of them I which is
the next one
um so here was a pair was age but if I
removed that loop from H then the age
started that I get has a trivial
component so I can't tell by induction
how hard that is or if I think this is
what Martin was proposing if I added a
loop to that vertex but H star would be
equal to H and then I'd be getting
nowhere with the induction and anyway
there might be multiple vertices of
maximum degree anyway so all of these
are problems with pulling the skin
forward what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
talk first about this third one because
I think it's a little easier to explain
and I just want to give you a flavor of
how how this sort of thing goes okay all
right so here's in the car and I wanna
give you an example where there are
multiple vertices of maps
it's agreed to show you what sort of
things we could we can do about it
okay so I'm gonna switch the graph H and
here's the new H I want to look at okay
this is just to give you a flavor and
what happens now
what is the degree of this vertex one
two three four solute counts as one this
is also degree four so actually every
vertex in this graph know what is the
graph induced by v1 here well it's that
and what's the graph induced by anything
else like this vertex
well it looks like that okay now suppose
now it turns out to be true that both of
these guys are non-trivial they're both
pissed hard so to get the kind of
induction to go forward I'd want to use
the fact that these guys are hard just
show that that's hard yeah okay so what
I'm gonna do next is show you why that's
really easy to do in the sampling world
and then talk a little bit about how so
here's how you would solve the problem
in the sampling world and I think this
gives an intuition about the sort of
area so let's sum well I know that this
graph h1 is this hard and I know that
this crap h2 is this hard those are just
facts for my induction and let's move to
the sampling world so let's say that and
it's true that um
let me call this ih1 and that guy h2
that I've got sampling reductions from
sampling independent sets to sampling h1
colorings and to sampling h2 colorings
let's say so so that if I sampled an h1
coloring of the graph if I could do that
idea
independence up to the bipartite graph
equally if not can sample h2 colorings
that would do the trick but I don't want
to show that if I could symbol H
colorings that I'd be able to sample
independent sets into bipartite graph
okay so here's the cute and easy trick
for the sampling world great I've got an
instance of this graph and I want to
count independent sets okay
what do I do well I use the known
reduction to create an Instagram g1 such
that if I could count h1 colorings of g
one I'd be done also i construct a graph
g 2 so that i could construct each two
colors that you two might be done now
what do we do i flew them together makes
just some little bird next w and now
let's think about what happens if we
simple an h coloring of composite well
if I sample an H coloring of this
composite thing I have no idea in
advance what color W is gonna be but it
might be this color and if it's this
color then what's induced here is a
uniformly random h1 coloring of G 1
which is just what I want but if it's
this color I'm sorry to say that color
sorry then what that'll be there
so what's induced here is a uniformly
random h2 coloring of G 2 so if I look
it I don't know in advance what color W
is gives me but once I get the sample I
can look at it and I know which side to
look at to recover what I want okay so
that's that's a reduction in the
sampling world using the trick that I
don't have to know in advance what comes
back ok and ok now here's what would
happen if we did the same gain in the
counting world suppose I just wanted to
count H colorings of this composite like
so if I wanted to kicked out h1 to this
composite thing what would I get
well I get well I might put color v1
there so I get h1 colorings of g 1 times
h1 colorings of g 2 or there's four
other that might go there and for all
those I get h2 colorings of g 1 times h2
colors of g 2 and the point I want you
to take away from this is that if you
know the left hand side it's very hard
to draw conclusions about either H 1
colorings or H 2 coloring so that's what
sampling is easier to work in and there
may be other example of these H
colorings of the first term exactly I've
seen where the samplings are so much
easier to work in okay but I'll tell you
five minutes four minutes I'll tell you
just roughly how some nice ideas of
lavash help us to get around this
problem there's a problem thing if we
knew which one dominated we'd be done
but it's very hard to know that in
advance okay all right so we'll just so
we have just somehow choose between
these and there in general there might
be more than two possibilities so here's
the tools that that are helpful from
graph homomorphisms so um leverage
projection 67 is that if two graphs are
um not as the more fitted then there's
another graph which I'm calling J such
that they're not h1 colorings of J the
number of them is different from the
number of h2 color and sub J so this is
saying that there are two
h1 and h2 that are not isomorphic then
there's some graph J so that you can
distinguish between how many h1 coloring
- felony h2 colorings and it's pretty
easy to just give it a small extension
of this which says that if you have
pairwise non isomorphic perhaps h1 up to
H teeth then there's actually one of
these guys that just dominates so
there's some I star in one up to T and J
such that the number of a chives are
coloring is bigger than the rest so if I
have a bunch of paralyzing on isomorphic
graphs and I don't know which one I'm
gonna get there exist some broth J which
will dominate okay so I think the last
slide I'm going to show you is gonna be
how I would solve this example using
such a J so the little problem we foot
problem we were stuck with is we had the
graph H 1 and the graph H 2 and we
didn't really know which one would come
up so what we do is using the theorem of
lovers we know but there's some graph J
for which one of them will be more
dominant than the other here there are
only two there might have been more and
what we do is which is glue resilient
property copies of J on there and now
this vertex W really will be whichever
one it was H 1 and now we can proceed as
we did in the sampling world okay so
obviously there's a lot of them there's
a lot of complications but anyway I
think what I want to do is to stop with
the theorem and yeah back to the serum
so it turns out to a work
forever there we go but what we know
then is that if you take any fixed age
it turns out this in British production
skim-coat goes through and if you take
any fixed age then we can do this
induction and it turns out they're all
bit hard okay so the classification
program is by no means complete and
that's for two reasons
okay so the first is what we know is
there the trivial ages we can count
their colorings exactly
we know everything else is this hard but
we don't know what which ones are
disheartened which ones are sad hard so
that's an open area and the middle for
loopy thing is an example that makes it
move in between there
the second open problem is look I only
classified graphs where there are no
non-trivial components and of course if
you add trivial components some of them
get easy and we have known our theorem
so that's also still an open problem so
there's lots work like to do but at
least we know there's nothing easier
than this okay
I guess the longer work in this film
went into proving that or H you can find
a sub graph H prime so that this review
yeah so it didn't have to be a sub prime
but it didn't have to be a sub graph so
did I make life any easier or you don't
know but you didn't know how to do it in
the other way but yeah there's no reason
why it should be a sub graph except for
that in fact in real true that day I
mean actually what we do is we kind of
bipartite the whole thing and so it's a
sub graph of something else but but
there's no reason why it should be a sub
graph anyway of course you're right it's
just that that's what we could do
again professionals race before this
number base so if whether it is an
intermediate problem so there are no
collapse earrings so it down it's a
nothing now
excellent so the question was in Casey
would there be any nice collapses if you
resolved well number bits like if it was
in the P by M principle would you get a
collapse or something no we don't know
anything like that